Hallo, Schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag. Lala ist meine Name und ich bin eine der
Stationsärzte und heute bin ich für Sie zuständig. Und ja, wenn Sie damit
auch einverstanden sind, würde ich dieses Aufnahmere-Sprechdurchführ
gerne. Und wie heißen Sie? Schmidt-Claudia.
Claudia Schmidt.
Und ja, wie alt sind Sie?
67 Jahre alt.
Wie viel wiegen Sie? 80 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie? 170.
170. Okay. Und was wird Sie zu uns? Warum wurde der Asken der
Nass gesagt? Ja, mir ist in der Letzten Zeit mit dem Luft
fällt bisschen schwer. Vor allem wenn ich treppe auch steige
und treppe auch laufe, ich habe Probleme mit dem Atom.
Ich weiß nicht genau, so ein Druckgefühl im Brust und
manchmal einen Husten, könnte ich nicht genau nachvollziehen,
weil kommt es. Und seit wann haben Sie diese Werte?
Ja, es ist eigentlich, ich hatte ab und zu schon gehabt,
ist das vorletztes, muss ich sagen, 3 bis 4 Monaten,
kann ich nicht genau sagen, aber wenn ich jetzt
überlege, ihr mich an, das ist seit 3, 4 Monaten, es kann da
auch sein, bis dann länger. Ist das langsam aufgetreten
oder? Ja, das ist langsam aufgetreten, genau.
Okay. Und jetzt leiten Sie auch
unter Luftnot oder haben Sie abtuell Brustschmerzen
oder? Wenn ich sitze, im Ruhe habe ich gar kein Problem.
Nur bei Belastung, beim Laufen und Treppe
auch steigen bei denen, ansonsten im Ruhe habe ich gar kein Problem.
Okay, jetzt sind Sie schon in Ruhe und haben Sie
keine Schmerzen? Nein, ich habe gar keine, mindestens
habe keine Atom-Root, nehme ich so an, wie Sie das sehen,
das weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich habe mich für Sie mich ganz wohl jetzt.
Okay, das ist gut. Und ja,
diese Luftnot treten meistens
unter Belastung auf und
wie viele Menge Belastung
meinen Sie? Wie viele Menge Belastung,
Menge kann man nicht genau sagen hier, aber
nehme ich an, wenn ich jetzt in den 2-Tage auch
laufe, sondern bei 3-Tage
muss ich schon Pause machen,
weil es ist nicht so schlimm natürlich, aber trotzdem
ist besser, dass ich diese Pause mache, ansonsten, wenn noch schlimmer
habe ich das Eindruck, ja, daher,
wenn ich ganz normal laufe, zum Einkauf zum Beispiel,
ja, sondern nach 3-400 m
ist es ein bisschen schwer.
Okay, und
haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Eigentlich ist es nicht bekannt.
Nehmen Sie irgendwie mit Gemeinte ein?
Ja, aktuell nicht, ab und zu habe ich so einen Gledenschmerzen,
ein Bauchschmerzen,
eine Basatamol oder Epiphofen, aber die sind bei Bedarf
je nach, ist es nicht regelmäßig.
Okay, und haben Sie schon bemerkt, dass Ihre
Gledern, Füßen, ist schon
großer geworden, ist schon geschworen?
Ob die Beine geschworen, meinen Sie? Ja.
Nein, eigentlich auch. Ja, wenn ich viel laufe,
ja, schon ein bisschen, aber es ist nicht ausgeprägt, ja.
Kann ich nicht jetzt genau einschätzen, natürlich
tagsüber vielleicht schon etwas, aber nachts, wenn ich ins Bett gehe,
morgen früh ist wieder alles normal.
Okay, und
so in der letzten Zeit haben Sie ungewirrt
oder abgenommen?
Ich habe eher ein bisschen, ich habe da einen Druck, das ich
bestimmt zugenommen habe, sondern zwei Kilo.
Welche Zeitraum?
Seit umhörst du in drei Wochen?
Okay, und
wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Eigentlich gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder
Wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich gar kein Problem.
Okay, und leiden Sie unter
Nachtschweiß- oder Schweißausbruch?
Nur einfach, wenn ich mich belaste, natürlich.
Im Zeitpunkt habe ich ein bisschen Schweißausbruch,
aber Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht mehr.
Ja, in der Nacht
heißt die Frage, ja, schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich schlafe schon gut.
Können Sie ganz flach schlafen?
Gute Frage.
Ich schlafe nie ganz flach, sowieso, ja, nicht so gewöhnt.
Ich habe keine große Kisten, aber ohne Kisten kann ich nicht schlafen.
Ich habe es nicht probiert, kann ich nicht genau beantworten.
Aber ohne Kisten kann ich nicht schlafen, das ist klar.
Und ja,
bekommen Sie auch beim Schlafen eine Luftnot?
Nee.
Prusten oder machen Sie viel mehr zu Atmen?
Während Belastung natürlich, wenn ich mich belaste, ja.
Und sonst dann nicht.
Nein, flachlegen eigentlich.
Und sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe so ein GW-Moteinfernung bekommen,
ungefähr fast 30 Jahre.
Und ansonsten so eine Belindarminsinnung hatte ich auch gehabt,
vor 20 Jahren, wurde auch entfernt.
Ansonsten ja, anderes habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay, und GW-Moteinfernung,
wann war das genau?
Ungefähr 30 Jahre, ich kann nicht genau sagen, aber fast 30 Jahre.
Ja.
Und diese Belindarm-Entfernung auch,
fast 20 Jahre.
Und ja, trinken Sie Alkohol?
So, gelegentlich, ja, so ein, alles seit 3 Wochen mal,
so eine Eingrasswein.
Und rauchen Sie?
Auch nicht mehr. Ich habe noch auch, aber nicht mehr.
Wie viel haben Sie schon geraucht?
Wie lange und wie viel, ja.
Ungefähr 20 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Damals habe ich so ein, zwei Schachtel, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe viel geraucht damals.
Okay, das ist ja gut, dass Sie das auch gehört haben.
Haben Sie erfahrend mit drungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Nein, auch nicht bekannt.
Und ist Ihre Eltern schon am Leben?
Nein.
Sie sind schon aufweiter.
Und voran die beiden gestorben?
Ja, vor zehn Jahren.
Die hatte, also Lungenkrebs gehabt.
War schon 6, 7 Monate unter Therapie.
Und danach hat es nicht mehr geschafft.
Und meine Vater hat auch Herzprobleme gehabt.
Und man sieht,
dass das eine Problem ist
ein Herzinsuffizienz oder hat er auch
einen Herzinfarkt gehabt?
Das kann ich nicht genau jetzt beantworten.
Aber der hatte das Probleme.
Ich habe es nie genau nachgefragt,
was das Hintergrund war.
Das Problem weiß ich nicht genau.
Aber als er alt war,
er wurde gestorben.
Er war ungefähr 75 Jahre alt.
Und arbeiten Sie?
Nicht mehr.
Letztes Jahr.
Schon berendet sind Sie?
Ja, schon berendet.
Leiden Sie unter Stress?
Unter Stress?
Stress? Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe gemütliches Leben.
Ich bin gerade frisch im Rennen.
Und der Henke versucht es zu genießen.
Aber es scheint nicht das Problem zu sein.
Sie können den genießen.
Aber jetzt sollen wir die Osa finden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe Zeug Kinder.
Sind sie gesund? Ja, die sind gesund.
Die sind auch gesund.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, habe ich keine.
Ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, kann ich gerne antworten.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Was steht mir vor? Was haben Sie vor Plan?
Damit ich das wissen kann, wie es weitergeht.
Jetzt gehe ich davon aus,
dass Sie eine Herzinstifizienz haben können.
Das können wir als Arztgespräch machen.
Damit wir das überspringen und Zeit gewinnen.
Wir enden jetzt Arztgespräch.
Wenn meine Kollegen eine Frage haben.
Haben Sie noch Kollegen?
Wo haben Sie eine lange Reise?
gute Frage.
Vor 3 Monaten,
ich habe eine Reise nach Ursa gehabt.
Ich habe nicht mehr eine Reise.
Aber ich habe eine Reise nach Ursa gehabt.
Wo sah gehabt?
Das war fast nicht schon noch im Her.
In ungefähr 20 Stunden natürlich.
Das war nicht aber in einem Schnitt, sondern ich war dahin und zwei Wochen war ich zum
Wandeln und dann kam ich wieder zurück.
Seitdem habe ich ein bisschen Probleme, muss ich sagen.
Haben Sie sich geblieben?
Nein.
Ich habe Ausfuhr.
Als ich so vor kam, aber seit dem Monat habe ich gar keine Kunst.
Was steht im Folgenden Grund? Atemnot oder Brustschmerzen?
Atemnot.
Durch Druckgefühl habe ich natürlich Probleme, aber direkt Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Durch Brustschmerzen ist nur bei Belastung auf.
Info nicht gefragt.
Genau.
Heute ist aktuell, heute ist Tag gemacht, muss man alle empfunden.
Corona geimpft oder nicht?
Obwohl nicht mehr Geld.
Und Herzrahmen?
Gut, gute Frage.
Ja, Herzrahmen.
Für Rechtsmedizin, Herzrahmen spielt gerne Rolle.
Aber wenn ich Atemnot habe, dann habe ich ein bisschen Herzrahmen.
Spüre ich schon.
Das ist das.
Können wir als das jetzt anfangen?
Ja, machen wir.
Wenn wir keine Fragen haben mehr.
Ja, und haben noch Fragen?
Ähnliche Beschwerden.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen als gewesen?
Nein, ich habe es gedacht, das geht von sich alleine jetzt.
In der letzten Zeit, die Probleme hat sich vermehrt.
Dann habe ich gesagt, gehe ich mal zum Arzt, damit ich das klären kann.
Aber wo kommt das?
Ich habe es gesagt, ich habe seit 67 Jahren keine Foreer-Krankungen.
Timro.
Ja.
Seit 67 Jahren und keine Foreer-Krankungen, keine Artillerie, Pertonen, Diabetes.
Das ist normal?
Natürlich.
Hier ist normal.
Okay.
Bei euch war das nicht normal.
Das ist 80 Jahre, keine Medikamente.
Die sagen, die anderen genießen, haben nichts ein, haben gesund gewesen.
Meine Pause ist gefragt.
Das hat aber kommt auch nicht Frage.
Mit Frage 67 wird man auch nicht mehr aktiv.
Und der nimmt regelmäßig ihre Vorsorge und untersucht.
Ja, gute Fahrer.
Gehen Sie zum Frauenarzt.
Ja, das mache ich.
Und jetzt ab der letzten Ordnung.
Ja, genau.
Das letzte Gebäud ist Frau, dann habe ich meine Ruhe.
Okay.
Jetzt fangen wir an.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, wenn Sie Zeit haben, würde ich gerne an Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, gerne. Hallo.
Frau Schymit, 67 Jahre gelge Patienten.
Und ja, sie städte sich bei uns wegen der seit 3, 4 Monaten bestehenden
progederenden Luftnot.
Und ja, sie berichtet auch Druckgefühl und Wusten bei Belastung.
Und diese Beschwerden treten meistens unter Belastung mit 2 Atenen aufsteigen
oder 300 oder 300, 400 Metern laufen auf.
Und in den letzten 3 Wochen hat sie umgewehrt 2 Klubrahmen zugenommen.
Und sie hatte kein Vorerkrankungen und nimmt sie Nobelbewerber auf
Prasatomol oder irgendeine Schimassmedikation ein.
Und ja, vor 30 Jahren ist sie, ist der Doktomi schon durchgeführt vor 30 Jahren
und von Doktomi-Operationen vor 20 Jahren ist schon bekannt bei ihr.
Keine Allergie bekannt und ja, gelegentlicher Alkoholkonsum ist schon,
wurde schon angegeben und sie hat früher geraucht, jetzt schon ausgehört,
aber früher 20 Jahren täglich ein bis zwei Schachten schon treten geraucht
und keine Erfahrung betrogen.
In der Familienanamnase, ja, ihr Vater ist schon wegen einer Hassprobleme gestorben
und ja, ihre Mutter ist vor 10 Jahren an einem anderen Brunscher Katzenau gestorben
und sie ist beräntet und kein Stressvater in ihrer Leben schon vorhanden.
Und ja, unter Berichtsuchtigung dieser Beschwerden gehe ich davon aus,
dass sie ja wegen der Herzinsuffizienz haben können, haben kann
und ja, zusätzlich kann auch ja, ein Angenapektor ist
und in Frage kommen, ja, vielleicht, die kann auch annämmig sein,
dass, was sollen wir mit der Blutbild bestimmen.
Okay, ja, aber jetzt würde ich gern die Patienten versuchen.
Okay, das heißt, zusammenzufassen, eine 67-jährige Patientin
stellt sie sich mit einem Belastungdissignal, die seit 3, 4 Monaten bestehen
vor und hat keine Husten aktuell, keine Infiktezeichen
und klinisch ist ein Rohrstervil auch aktuell, dann beginnen wir vor jetzt.
Was haben Sie jetzt als Plan?
Das ist Ihrer Vater, der ist ein Oberkanzler.
Ja, das ist Ihr recht widersünftes Fall.
Jetzt soll ich die Untersuchung unbedingt und ja, bestimmen,
soll ich bestimmen, ob die Patienten jetzt irgendeiner Herzrasen hat oder...
Was sagten Sie bei Körperuntersuchung? Was wollen Sie denn machen?
Und ich tasse der Herz ab und den Herz ab und dann habe ich den Herz ab.
Partaktion, Auskultation und Lumen...
Was soll ich unbedingt...
Spultation und Herz und noch.
Und Herz auch und...
N?
Und was erwarten Sie bei Lumen?
Spultation, was wollen Sie denn damit auslösen?
Das könnte auch pläverale Effisionen nicht stimmen, wenn es sich schon vorhanden ist.
Und ja, kann auch.
Das könnte auch bei Percussion machen, oder?
Ja, bei Percussion.
Und man heute ist eigentlich nichts mehr macht, aber das ist alte Methode.
Der Einfachste, dass man mit der Wuternsteine einfach mal...
Die Autorotoroschale, ja.
Okay, aber Sie wollen einfach so ein anomalisches Nungengeräusch, so ein Atemgeräusch ausstehen, ob sie gerade hat oder nicht.
Das ist schon mal wichtig.
Was ist die Situation? Was wollten Sie achten?
Oder was beachten Sie genau?
Ja, wenn es um die Herzinsuffizienz geht, dann kann ich irgend eine Haftursache finden, wie Klappenstunner oder Klappeninsuffizienz.
Stunner ist ja der Terminalverdacht, genau.
So ein Erhältsgeräusch, dann eine Ahnung.
Erhältsgeräusche, kann ich auch.
Stunner ist das Metral oder ist das Autor, klar.
Da kann man das bisschen lokalisieren und als patologisches Geräusch und die Grad notieren.
Okay, das haben Sie gemacht. Was achten Sie noch bei dem Körperuntersuchung?
Und die Jambeinodämme, so wie ich auch prüfen, ob ich sie auch verwenden.
Und überhaupt plus, jetzt fehlt mir nicht mehr ein.
Ja, so ein Allgemein kann man sagen, ich versuche dann lieber voll grösserungen, ob denn Patienten hatten, die sind voll grösserungen.
Ja.
Und dann kann man auch noch mit Abticken ausschließen oder nicht.
Das hat den Körperuntersuchung.
Okay, was machen Sie als Nächstes und was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose her?
Okay, dann...
Die ganze Untersuchung geht um Richtung, dass Sie eine Verdachtdiagnose versuchen,
um uns zu bestätigen oder mindestens herauszuführen, damit Sie die nächste Stufe nach dem Körperuntersuchung einfach in die Welt leiten.
Und ja, wenn die Patienten schon bei der Untersuchung ist und Hassgeräusche hat und auch eine teurelle Vision oder eine...
Der ist ja gerade dann, das ist gar nicht eine Herz-Urv.
Okay, das machen Sie, um einfach seine hessentzifizienz zu bestätigen oder auszustehen.
Ja, richtig.
Dann machen Sie auch eine Röntgen-Torax, um einfach seine Lunge in die Stadion zu sehen, wie das ist.
Okay, aber meine Frage geht zum, was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose, bevor Sie diese ganze Sache machen,
damit Sie in dieser Richtung gehen, um genau zu wissen, was Sie machen mussten oder woran.
Dass Sie standard drücken, machen Sie standard sehr gut, Sie machen U-Kan-Gegen sehr gut, Sie machen Blutinnahme, was sagten Sie bei Blutinnahme?
Was machen Sie?
Ja, mindestens, ja, kleine Bilder, Bildbild und...
Große Bildbild?
Ja, und vielleicht, ja, BNNP, BNNP Protein, kann ich auch bestimmen, da für die Herz-Urv. ins Zufizienz bestätigen.
Bei der Verdacht auf Rungen im Budi, was machen Sie denn?
Ja, Dedima-Werte.
Aber vor allem, was machen Sie noch?
Großes Blutbild ist das Blutbild.
Sie haben keine Nierenfunktion dort, Sie haben keine Leberfunktion dort, Sie haben keine Blüte.
Da sollen Sie nicht verwirkt sein.
Großes Blutbild ist eine diffusivisierende Blutbild.
Sie brauchen eine große Routine, das ist etwas anderes.
Große Routine ist das alles drin.
Wo ist das Blutbild, noch die andere Labo-Werte, noch das so.
Die zwei Blutbilds...
Der war doch auch näher in Retentions-Weltern.
Das ist richtig, weil wenn Sie eine Routine haben, dann kann man auch eine Nieren-Inz-Ufizienz dahinter stecken.
Da müssen Sie das auch beobachten und aufnehmen, in den Blutuntersuchen.
Das haben Sie in der Tarn-Leber-Werte auch mitgemacht und richtig pro BNP, genau richtig,
ob man eine Kardialprobleme hinter hat oder nicht muskulatorisch muss man sagen.
Und Dedima haben Sie auch gemacht, Dedima ist auch, und das macht man.
Dedima ist auch.
Und das ist nicht bestimmt, dass Sie Lungenembolli haben.
Das zu prüfen, sollen wir auch eine CT-Torax oder CT-Antiografie... CT-Torax, Antiografie.
CT-Torax ist nicht so eine Pulmonal-Angio, sagt man das.
Die Pulmonal-Angio.
Ja, die Pulmonal-Angio.
Weil bei CT-Torax sehen Sie die Präfer-Lungenembolli nicht ganz genau.
Ja, da ist die.
Zentral-Lungenembolli sehen Sie das genau, als recht Medizine,
aber die Präfer-Lungenembolli würden Sie nicht sehen.
Da voran ist eine Pulmonal-Angio, dann sehen Sie alles.
Und in diesem Fall auch wahrscheinlich ist es eine Präfer-Lungenembolli,
nehme ich an, weil bei Zentral dann kommt, was denn sofort mit Luftnot,
mit stärkeren Luftnot, die können nicht das einfach jetzt 3, 4 Monate halten.
Dass Sie selten auch zu sehen, dass bei Sinemitzowas kommt,
den Notaufnahme, aber in diesem Fall, was Sinemitz verweigert hinterher,
hat eine noch dazu, auch wahrscheinlich noch eine Herzrichtesbelastung,
langsam, langsam, die entgegelt sein könnte sein.
Dafür braucht man dann natürlich etwas, der UKG, wie Sie gesagt haben, genau richtig.
Und Pulmonal-Angio haben Sie gemacht, der hat sich bestätigt mit der Präfer-Lungenembolli,
einer kundlichen Präfer-Lungenembolli, nicht akut ist sozusagen.
Da sieht man ganz selten, aber es geht um nicht das,
wie die seltenen Falls zu diskutieren,
dass man die Präse-Dürre einfach auch bei akut ist, die gleiche Art,
dass Sie, was man angehen muss.
Und was wir vergessen haben in der Notaufnahme, Sie müssen auch eine BGA auch machen.
Sie brauchen eine EKG auch, ja.
Das kann auch sein, dass man sie in einer Herz-Rhythmesturung,
neben Schaf-Vorflimmern auch hat.
Das kommt auch hinterher nach der Männeralungenembolli,
wo man nicht achtet und hat immer wieder eine Herz-Rhythmesturung,
die so kardial insoffizient am Ende verursacht.
Und daher hat man auch diese Probleme.
Und weil es Ihnen auch Herzrasen gehabt hat,
das während der Belastung habe ich auch Herzrasen.
Das passt, das könnte auch sein, dass eine Herzinsuffizienz
durch akutes Herzprobleme, durch eine andere Ursache bekommen.
Daher EKG, BGA, großes Routine und die weitere Nachbedürfnisse.
Wenn Sie eine pulmonale Angestätin machen,
brauchen Sie keine Errünterung, dann haben Sie es.
Daran haben Sie Kostenabdeckung, da sind wir mal hinterher geschicken,
dann habe ich alles drin.
Und der Resttherapies, klar, was macht man?
Ein Antikorbenlastienter.
Nordkastienter hat 4, 5 Sorten und dann eine von dem gibt man
eine Startmagnetentherapie.
Da gehen wir nicht rein.
Aber vor so etwas, vor unklares, natürlich, der hatte lange Reise gehabt,
aber nehme ich an, dass die Patient keine lange Reise hatte.
Was machen Sie denn bei unklarer Schädenembolli?
Dann geht noch tiefer.
Bei unklares Lungenembolli, dann müssen Sie natürlich
die Beine unbedingt doppler machen.
Egal, was das ist, hat eine Turmose runter.
Obwohl es nicht stark geschworen ist.
Noch dazu, dann würde ich den Patient zu einer Turmoforsorgeuntersuchung schicken.
Ich gehe mal, weil selten Patient kommen wird so etwas rein
und die haben eine Turmose, die man nicht weiß.
Und die, die sind gerne ambulieren.
Und natürlich, denn diese Lungen oder Algenbrillen,
oder die Patient kommen mit Schlagrenfau rein
und sagen, die hat dann eine Turmose, der hat das nicht verkehrt in diesem Alter gemacht.
Sie haben es aber toll gemacht, müsste ich sagen.
Sie haben Prüfung oder wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Ja, nächste Woche Donnerstag.
Sie haben es bestanden, dann ist das so.